Spider-Man has been featured in numerous movies
and hundreds of TV episodes, and many actors
have gotten a chance to portray the iconic
web-slinger.
Here's a look at the major versions of Spider-Man
from TV and movies, as well as the actors
who played them, ranked from worst to best.
It isn't Nicholas Hammond's fault that barely
anybody remembers the short-lived "Amazing
Spider-Man" TV show from the late 1970s; he
just didn't have much to work with.
With no supervillains and only several familiar
faces from the comics, Hammond's take on the
character feels less like a superhero and
more like a regular guy in a red jumpsuit.
"The Amazing Spider-Man" aired on CBS alongside
"The Incredible Hulk," but while the latter
show turned out to be a hit that defined the
character for years, "Amazing Spider-Man"
would only ever be a footnote in Spider-Man's
long history.
"Spider-Man Unlimited" was an attempt to extend
the '90s animated series past its sell-by
date by recasting Spider-Man and sending him
to a darker alternate Earth.
Rino Romano does very little to make the character
his own, instead making an effort to sound
exactly like his predecessor, Christopher
Daniel Barnes.
His costume, inspired by the "Spider-Man 2099"
comics, certainly looks cool, but would probably
have fit better in an actual "Spider-Man 2099"
cartoon adaptation.
Paul Soles as Spider-Man sounds the way people
in the 1960s expected a superhero to sound
— which means his voice is a little deeper
than the depictions of Peter Parker we see
today.
Soles does his best getting into the role,
but it's clear that this first "Spider-Man"
cartoon, which ran from 1967 to 1970, isn't
very interested in characterization.
This version of Spider-Man is perhaps best
remembered today as the star of many animated
GIFs.
The 1981 "Spider-Man" animated series isn't
bad by any means: the animation is solid for
the time, and it brings in a lot of villains
from the comics who'd never gotten TV time
before.
Ted Schwartz does an admirable job bringing
this iteration of Spider-Man to life, bringing
more individuality to the role than most had
before him.
The strange thing about this show is that
it was immediately overshadowed by a different
Spider-Man cartoon.
"Spider-Man and His Amazing Friends," which
premiered the same day, features more Marvel
heroes and a stronger lead performance by
Dan Gilvezan.
The two series also feature nearly identical
animation styles and character designs, which
can make for a disorienting viewing experience.
Unfortunately for Schwartz, this is a series
that many have chosen to forget.
"Boy, some days it hardly pays to be a lovable
superhero."
Spider-Man's very first live-action appearance
was on "The Electric Company," a 1970s educational
series that ran on PBS.
This Spider-Man doesn't talk and never appears
out of costume, but his simple adventures
and easily-described actions are the perfect
vehicle for teaching kids basic language and
math skills.
The show also has a lot of fun bringing the
comic book aesthetic to life, with Danny Seagren
often framed by comic book panels and "speaking"
with the aid of word balloons.
It's a trick to get children to read, of course,
but it does so with plenty of fun and personality.
Admittedly, this is kind of an odd one.
In 1990, Spider-Man starred in a short PSA
about child abuse that was distributed to
schools and libraries.
There's no Green Goblin or Mysterio here,
just a father who hits his daughter and a
group of kids who turn to Spider-Man for help.
Spider-Man tells them that violence is never
the answer and recommends a hotline to call.
Spider-Man doesn't have a whole lot to do
here, since the spotlight is on the kids,
but he's well portrayed by veteran voice actor
Greg Snegoff, credited here as Gregory Snow.
He's reminiscent of the '80s animated Spider-Man,
and, more importantly, has a warmth to him
when interacting with troubled children.
He comes off as an adult you can trust, which
is both perfect for this cartoon and exactly
what Spider-Man should be.
Given time and a "Spider-Verse" sequel or
two, this Spider-Man of the future could potentially
move much higher on this list.
After all, Spider-Man 2099, a.k.a. geneticist
Miguel O'Hara, has a cult following all his
own.
On top of that, he's voiced by the incredibly
popular Oscar Isaac of "Star Wars" and "Ex
Machina" fame.
The problem, of course, is that he's barely
in "Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse" at
all, appearing only in the film's after-credits
sequence.
It's fun to see him reenact a famous meme
from the 60's Spider-Man show, but it's an
inauspicious beginning for Miguel.
We can only hope that he'll have more of a
presence in "Spider-Verse 2."
Two big things are distracting about 2003's
"Spider-Man: The New Animated Series," a more
mature take on the comics that aired on MTV,
of all places.
The first is the animation, which combines
2D cartooning with 3D computer modeling in
an incredibly awkward way.
The second is that every time Neil Patrick
Harris' version of Spider-Man talks, it's
hard not to imagine Doogie Howser or Barney
Stinson under the red and blue suit.
Harris wasn't a bad choice for Spider-Man
at the time, but it's difficult to accept
him as Peter Parker today when his voice has
become so recognizable as a musical TV star.
Out of all the Spider-Man cartoons since the
60s, this one has probably aged the worst.
Everybody loves Miles Morales, the modern
teenage Spider-Man created by Brian Michael
Bendis and Sara Pichelli in 2011 for Marvel's
now-defunct Ultimate Comics line.
Even when the Ultimate line ended, Miles and
his supporting cast managed to survive, thanks
to his popularity and the unique flavor he
adds to the Spider-Man franchise.
Unfortunately, bringing him into the 2017
"Spider-Man" animated series just didn't work
that well.
Rather than originating from an alternate
dimension, this version of Miles, played by
Nadji Jeter, is nothing more than a school
friend of Peter Parker's who gains his own
powers and dons his own costume.
When he first goes into action, he's portrayed
as a sloppy and overly enthusiastic hero who
initially does a very bad job — Peter has
to act as a coach and mentor, despite being
somewhere around Miles' age.
The whole storyline feels shoehorned in, and
robs Miles Morales of much of what makes him
such a compelling character.
Gwen Stacy has been a part of Spider-Man's
story in the comics since 1965, but it's only
recently she's gained superpowers of her own.
Known to the world as Spider-Woman and to
her friends as Spider-Gwen, this web-slinger
has been a fan favorite since she first donned
the white and pink suit in 2014.
The Gwen Stacy of the 2017 "Spider-Man'' series,
however, suffers from a similar problem as
Miles Morales: she's a schoolmate of Peter's,
rather than the main spider-person of her
own world.
Unfortunately, this take on Gwen seems less
like her own superhero and more like just
another spidey-sidekick.
Perhaps this show chose to avoid introducing
a multiverse because "Into The Spider-Verse"
was already in production, but both Spider-Gwen
and Miles Morales feel like cheap imitations
of their Spider-Verse incarnations as a result.
Still, veteran voice actor Laura Bailey does
her best with the material she's been given.
While Lego productions are known for drawing
heavily from their source material, 2015's
"Avengers Reassembled" actually came out before
Spider-Man's first MCU appearance in "Captain
America: Civil War."
With no Tom Holland performance to base Lego
Peter Parker off of, this plastic take on
Spidey is a bit generic compared to his counterparts
that aren't made out of bricks.
Still, Ben Diskin gives it his all in the
role, as he continues to do in the role of
Flash Thompson in the 2017 "Spider-Man" series.
Once the MCU established their own Spider-Man,
however, the Lego one had to evolve a bit
to keep up.
Cole Howard is an experienced and talented
young voice actor, and his work in 2020's
"Lego Marvel Avengers: Climate Conundrum"
certainly fits the character of Peter Parker.
However, it's fairly clear that Howard got
the part because his Spider-Man voice sounds
very much like Tom Holland's.
Howard's Spider-Man comes off as a bit younger
and a lot sillier than Holland's live-action
performance, but the similarity is still unmistakable.
For "Lego Marvel Avengers," which is basically
"the movies but sillier and aimed at younger
audiences," Cole Howard is doing exactly what's
needed for the part.
We're ranking the three spider-kids from this
Disney Junior series as a group rather than
individually, because frankly these versions
just aren't quite distinctive enough to warrant
their own entries.
"Spidey and His Amazing Friends" is aimed
at preschool kids, which means all the sharp
corners are pretty much sanded off.
Of course, that doesn't mean it's a bad show.
It's pleasant and likable enough, with each
episode featuring two short adventures in
which the Spidey team face similarly aged-down
supervillains and learn lessons about sharing
and so forth.
The villains include a really great female
Doc Ock who's basically a little girl version
of Kathryn Hahn from "Into the Spider-Verse."
"Give it up, Doc Ock!
You can't handle the Spidey Team!"
"But can you handle the might of Gigantapus
Squishy?!?"
As far as characterization goes, however,
there's just not much going on in a show like
this.
The Spidey Team is voiced by actual kids — and
talented ones at that — which does add to
the show's unique energy.
As kids' shows go, this one could certainly
be a lot worse, but it's not where adult fans
are going in search of great takes on Spider-Man
and his friends.
The very first Spider-Man introduced in "Spider-Man:
Into The Spider-Verse" is the Peter Parker
of Miles Morales' Earth, voiced by the absurdly
charismatic Chris Pine.
He's the big-time hero of New York, and basically
the perfect Spider-Man.
He even has blond hair, unlike any other version
of Peter Parker, to mark him as a literal
golden boy.
The problem, however, is that a flawless Spider-Man
doesn't feel like a Spider-Man at all: the
whole point of the character is that he's
a flawed hero and nothing ever seems to go
right for him.
This Spider-Man isn't in the movie to be a
character of his own, though: He's there to
provide an idealized image that conflicts
with the inexperienced Miles and the slovenly
Peter B. Parker.
Plus, making him the perfect superhero makes
the tragedy of his death that much greater,
especially as he leaves behind a legacy that
Miles must try and live up to.
Although the original "Spider-Man: Noir" comic
where this version of Peter Parker originated
is quite a serious affair, the version of
him that appears in "Into the Spider-Verse"
is essentially a one-note joke character.
Still, thanks to plenty of great lines and
a flawless voice performance by the peerless
Nicolas Cage, he's an extremely funny joke
character.
"Sometimes I let matches burn down to my fingertips
just to feel something, anything… aww.”
Not only does Spider-Man Noir sound like a
perfectly hard-boiled detective, he also looks
extremely striking, rendered entirely in black
and white halftone in a colorful world.
If he comes back in "Spider-Verse 2," it might
be fun to get to know him a little better,
but even if we don't, we're still incredibly
glad to have seen him in action.
The 1978 Japanese "Spider-Man" live-action
TV series has developed a cult following in
the U.S., even though it's never been officially
released here.
It was produced by the Toei Company, who later
created "Mighty Morphin' Power Rangers," and
they infused Spider-Man with a similar tokusatsu
vibe.
Shinji Tôdô plays Spider-Man's face and
voice, while Hirofumi Koga does much of the
performing inside the Spider-Protector suit.
In this series, Spider-Man is a motorcycle
driver named Takuya Yamashiro, who gets his
spider-powers from a super-bracelet from the
planet Spider.
Mostly, he does what American Spider-Man does
— climbing walls, spinning webs, and so
forth — but being a true tokusatsu hero,
he also has a race car and a giant robot named
Leopardon.
The show's a lot of fun, and Tôdô and Koga
both do a great job, but it drifts pretty
far from Spider-Man as we understand him.
These days, its primary appeal is definitely
the camp factor.
A far more streamlined and spidery mech than
Leopardon, Peni Parker's SP//dr isn't nearly
as big, but it has a lot more personality.
It's also co-piloted by an actual spider that
has a psychic link with young Peni, played
by Kimiko Glenn.
Together, they're the spider-heroes of a New
York in the year 3145 that exists somewhere
out in the Spider-Verse.
Peni and SP//dr are inspired by Japanese mecha
anime like "Neon Genesis Evangelion" and "Gundam."
Although Peni doesn't get too much character
development, she's a great example of just
how far a spider-hero can get from the standard
template we've seen time and time again.
She also provides some emotional punch in
the final battle, as SP//dr sacrifices himself
to save Peni.
Fortunately, she's able to save her spider
friend from inside the mech, so hopefully
they'll be able to rebuild upon returning
to their own dimension.
Of all the secondary spider-people in "Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse," Spider-Ham is by far
the silliest.
That works for him, though — in fact, it's
kind of the whole point.
Spider-Ham is essentially a Looney Tunes character,
down to his silhouette resembling Porky Pig.
He's even mastered cartoon physics, making
him one of the most unpredictable fighters
the Spider-Verse has to offer.
"What are you, some kind of silly cartoon?"
Spider-Ham's onscreen appearance is a departure
from the original comic book version of the
character, who starred in 1985's "Peter Porker,
the Spectacular Spider-Ham."
There, he's a little more serious, working
alongside other animal Avengers like Captain
AmeriCat and Iron Mouse.
In "Into the Spider-Verse," however, the silliness
of Spider-Ham makes for some of the movie's
funniest moments, largely thanks to a fantastic
voice performance from comedian John Mulaney.
By 2017, it was pretty established in the
minds of fans what a teenage Peter Parker
should sound like, and Robbie Daymond nails
it.
Aside from that, however, not much about this
version of the character feels fresh or new.
The 2017 "Spider-Man" is a solid, engaging
animated series, but it's all kind of been
done already.
It's fun to see Spider-Man team up with other
Marvel heroes, like Iron Man, Black Widow,
and The Hulk, but storylines featuring multiple
web-slinging characters lack the spark that
made them memorable in "Into the Spider-Verse."
Sometimes, it feels like the most daring part
of this "Spider-Man" incarnation is the way
his belt doesn't quite fully connect on the
front of his costume.
Still, if you're looking for a solid Spider-Man
voice performance, you could do a lot worse
than Robbie Daymond.
Back in the early days of 21st century superhero
movies, years before the MCU, Tobey Maguire
got the job done.
He got in great physical shape for Sam Raimi's
"Spider-Man" and its sequels, but kept the
charmingly goofy face that made Peter Parker
a relatable figure for audiences of all ages.
While he never quite seems like a kid the
way an early career Spider-Man should, he's
young-looking enough to sell a teenage performance
— even though he was in his late 20s when
production began.
In the emotional scenes, Maguire's always
a little over the top, but he makes up for
it with fun quips and killer dance moves.
He's definitely a solid Spider-Man, but nothing
to write home about.
"Ultimate Spider-Man" was controversial from
day one.
For one thing, it replaced the popular "Spectacular
Spider-Man'' series, which ended due to character
rights issues after Disney purchased Marvel
in 2009.
Some fans grew even more irritated when Drake
Bell of "Drake and Josh" fame was hired to
voice the title character, expecting that
this version of the character would be geared
for a younger, less mature audience.
However, if you ignore any bad publicity,
Bell is actually a pretty great animated Spider-Man.
He has a high capacity for silliness and fun,
as Spider-Man always should, but he also comes
through in the darker moments that require
a more emotional Peter Parker.
Although this iteration of Spider-Man may
not have gotten the same rave reviews that
"Spectacular Spider-Man's" Peter Parker did,
Bell certainly does the job.
The biggest problem with Andrew Garfield in
"The Amazing Spider-Man" is that he always
looked too old for the part.
Garfield may have made a good adult Peter
Parker if the script wrote him as such, but
a nearly thirty-year old man in the role of
a bullied high schooler is a hard sell to
the point that it almost never stops being
distracting.
Even still, Garfield's take on the wall crawler
has plenty going for him: he looks good in
the suit, his comedic timing is on point,
and his chemistry with Emma Stone's Gwen Stacy
makes for one of the best romantic storylines
that Spider-Man media has to offer.
Garfield is a fine transitional Spider-Man,
but not exactly the type that would have worked
best in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
For a lot of millennials, Christopher Daniel
Barnes was the definitive voice of Spider-Man
during their childhood, having played the
role on Fox Kids from 1994 to 1998.
While this "Spider-Man" series has aged a
little awkwardly, it was the first Spider-Man
TV show to draw on the comics' storylines
in a nuanced way, introducing characters like
Venom and even the Punisher to Saturday morning
viewers.
This series saves the origin story for the
theme song and begins with Peter Parker already
in college and freelancing for the Daily Bugle.
Within that context, Barnes is perfect in
the part, balancing the jokes and the emotional
baggage that are both so central to Spider-Man.
With its solid characterization and season-long
story arcs, this show is one of the best takes
on grown-up Peter Parker that you can find.
For those a little older, Dan Gilvezan is
the Saturday morning Spider-Man of choice.
He voices the wall crawling hero on "Spider-Man
and His Amazing Friends," a show that brought
the Marvel universe to life from 1981 until
1983.
Gilvezan was a mainstay of 1980s animation,
also known for his roles as Bumblebee in "Transformers"
and Cooler in "Pound Puppies."
His Spider-Man has the lightness that earlier
versions of the character had been missing,
while still seeming more grounded than his
goofier friend Iceman, played by Frank Welker.
This cartoon may seem pretty silly by today's
standards, but this was the first time Spider-Man
really felt like the Spider-Man we all know
today, and that's worth something.
Despite failing to gain momentum in the 2017
cartoon, Spider-Gwen thankfully got her chance
to shine as one of the numerous spider-people
featured in "Into the Spider-Verse."
As the one and only spider-hero of her world,
this incarnation of Gwen Stacy was motivated
to protect New York City by the death of her
best friend Peter Parker before getting sucked
into an extra-dimensional wormhole.
Despite rocky first impressions, Gwen becomes
a close friend to Miles, and despite a hint
of romantic tension, there's nothing too forced
or mushy to distract from daring heroics.
As far as spider-people go, Spider-Gwen is
one of the strongest: while Miles is new to
the game and Peter B.'s glory days are behind
him, Gwen is in the prime of her superhero
career: she's graceful, strong, and always
helpful in a pinch.
Hailee Steinfeld gives a standout voice performance
as Gwen, with the perfect mix of youthful
enthusiasm and effortless ability: she's not
exactly Spider-Man, but as far as spider-people
go, she's one of the best.
Peter Parker has always been a bit of a sad
sack, but Peter B. Parker from "Into the Spider-Verse"
takes it to a whole new level.
As the hero of New York for over two decades,
the years have taken their toll on Peter — as
he approaches 40, he finds himself broke,
separated from his wife Mary Jane, and gaining
a noticeable paunch.
He's the natural endpoint of Peter Parker's
bad luck, and the exact opposite of the Spider-Man
that Miles Morales grew up seeing.
However, once he realizes it's up to him to
mentor young Miles in the art of web-slinging,
he rediscovers the hero he's always been deep
down.
This is a take on Peter Parker that's never
quite been seen before, and wouldn't work
in most contexts — but in "Spider-Man: Into
the Spider-Verse," he's perfect, hilarious,
and ultimately touching.
Jake Johnson, star of TV's "New Girl," is
the perfect choice to voice this version of
the character, and gives a surprisingly nuanced
performance.
He may not be the best or most powerful Spider-Man,
but he might just be the most endearing one.
"Spectacular Spider-Man" is considered by
many to be the perfect 21st century Spider-Man
cartoon — and one that ended far too soon,
for frustrating reasons.
It ran for two seasons from 2008 to 2009,
and was being considered for a third when
Disney bought Marvel and reacquired the television
rights to Spider-Man, leaving this Sony-produced
series in legal limbo, unable to continue.
"Spectacular Spider-Man" takes Peter Parker
back to high school, with a unique new design
aesthetic that fits perfectly.
Voice actor Josh Keaton plays this youthful
Spider-Man with the earnestness of a kid trying
to do his best, and he couldn't have done
a better job.
It's just a shame we couldn't have seen more
of him.
Despite being the third live-action Spidey
inside of a decade, Tom Holland's take on
Peter Parker was a fan favorite from the moment
the world first saw him steal the vibranium
shield in the trailer for "Captain America:
Civil War."
Unlike Maguire and Garfield, however, Holland
has the authentic look and feel of an anxious
teenager who's gotten himself way in over
his head.
The genuine youthfulness and naiveté of Holland's
portrayal of Peter Parker contrasts perfectly
with the adult heroes of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, especially Iron Man.
Tony Stark's mentorship of Peter adds serious
emotional depth to both characters in a way
no other version of Spider-Man has done.
While Spider-Man is a character defined by
tragedy, no other actors have captured the
raw emotion of Peter Parker quite as effectively
as Holland has — as we've witnessed in one
of the most emotionally devastating moments
the MCU has to offer.
"I don't wanna go, I don't wanna go, sir,
please, please I don't wanna go, I don't wanna
go…"
As far as his solo efforts go, Holland's Peter
Parker is an awkward, yet charismatic young
hero who's still finding his place in the
world, trying to balance the life of an honor
student with the life of a superhero.
Even though he's constantly having to clean
up his own mistakes wherever he goes, he comes
across as inexperienced without ever seeming
incompetent, and by the end of "Far From Home,"
he's become a hero that Tony Stark would be
proud of.
All of this is topped off with a technological
marvel of a costume, which gives Spider-Man
the opportunity to be more expressive than
any other live-action version of him had been
before.
Details like this — combined with Tom Holland's
stellar performance — make for the best
Peter Parker outside of the comics themselves.
With apologies to all versions of Peter Parker,
Miles Morales is the Spider-Man of the future.
He's energetic, he's artistic, and as the
son of a Black father and a Puerto Rican mother,
he represents the changing face of America
in the best possible light.
As someone who grew up in Spider-Man's friendly
neighborhood, Miles finds himself with some
pretty big shoes to fill after the death of
his world's Peter Parker.
However, with some help from his family and
a half-dozen other spider-people, Miles is
able to figure out his abilities and become
the hero his city needs.
It's more than just his background that makes
Miles' Spider-Man unique, however — his
invisibility and venom strike abilities eventually
make him a fearsome foe for baddies like Kingpin.
Despite all the spider-people who appear throughout
"Into the Spider-Verse," it's Miles' story
first and foremost.
And just as it's the best Spider-Man movie
ever made, it shows how Miles has the potential
to be the best Spider-Man.
It certainly helps that he's voiced by Shameik
Moore from "The Get Down," who embodies the
character flawlessly.
It's only a matter of time until we see Miles
in live-action, whether he's replacing Peter
Parker or working alongside him.
Miles Morales is the future of Spider-Man,
and the future is bright.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Marvel characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.